IRENE VAN ZEELAND: Thanks for joining us here
today on this lovely or rainy afternoon!
My name is Irene Van Zeeland.
I work for the Holland Dance Festival as head
of education and outreach.
I'm a queer white woman mid 30s, blonde hair,
sitting in front of a bookshelf.
Today I'll be talking to Kate, who will introduce
herself.
KATE MARSH: My name is Kate.
I am a white crip woman, I have long brown
hair with a fringe.
I'm currently sitting in bed, the only room
I can escape my teenagers dog and cat.
I'm very happy to be here.
A tiny bit about my background.
I've worked in so called inclusive dance for
over 20 years now.
I'm a choreographer, I'm a researcher so I
work as a research fellow at a university,
and I also facilitate workshops and various
choreographic residencies and all manner of
things.
I'm very interested in rethinking leadership
in terms of dance and the arts and disability.
I'm very interested in crip theory and queer
theory and how these things can empower us
and give a framework to lots of thinking and
practice, amongst other things.
Just to give you a sense where the conversation
might go.
IRENE VAN ZEELAND: I think we're exactly here
to talk about you, so that was a nice start.
Thank you very much.
One thing I want to ask you is what at this
point in time makes your heart beat faster,
what gets you the most excited in this moment?
You have a long history researching and working
in the field.
Today what makes you most excited.
KATE MARSH: Great question.
I've become hooked on research.
In the last few years I've become - I enjoy
so much thinking about through my practice
and other outputs, written or speaking to
other people, really grounding what we do
as a sector and what we think in inter-research
terms.
That's important to me.
I feel passionate about that because crip
or disabled researchers are in a minority
in dance research, so I'm interested in growing
that.
On an emotional level, what really fires me
up - I'll age myself now - is the generation
behind me, when I encounter younger, hungrier,
less apologetic brilliant crip and disabled
artists.
They're not less polite, because they are
polite, but there is something - yeah they're
less polite maybe in what they're demanding.
That's really exciting and invigorating to
be around and be part of, and to get a sense
of what the future might be, and how those
of us who have done this work for a long time,
how that fed into younger generations.
I'm excited to see how they practice differently
and ask different questions.
IRENE VAN ZEELAND: Nice.
In the video we sent along with this invitation
you briefly spoke about that as well.
That is so exciting, this idea of the new
or young generation being unapologetic about
their place in the field of dance, gender
identity, climate change, many things - here
let's stick to the dance element.
I agree that's an exciting development.
What do you think we can learn from that attitude?
How can we use that to our advantage?
What about that inspires you to change also
maybe the way you think?
About the way you work?
KATE MARSH: Another great question.
This is perhaps a strange but practical answer.
I learn so much from upcoming generations
of crip artists actually around language.
You'll maybe note it's been recent for me
to lean into identifying as a crip person
and crip researcher.
I span a generation where it required such
a lot of explanation.
I'm learning from the language people use
to describe themselves and their work.
It's interesting you said the excitement relates
also to gender identity and climate change
- to me they're aligned, and crip artists
are often engaging.
We don't have to make work specifically around
disability.
We can exercise our expertise in other areas
as crip artists.
That's exciting to me, that I see many, many
crip artists making work just about their
knowledge of the body, the world or commenting
on something else.
That's a definite shift.
I come from a generation, I feel, where as
crip artists or disabled artists there was
an expectation to conform.
Lots of the labour of my work has been trying
to not erase my disability, but be in the
mainstream.
This was a repetitive thing.
When you're in the mainstream, if people don't
notice, you've made it.
I'm learning from younger artists a rejection
of the mainstream, less borrowing from a language
that exists, but creating a new language that
suits us.
I feel privileged to be around that and learn
that, and I feed it in to my practice.
IRENE VAN ZEELAND: If there is any moment
where you want to ask a question, don't hesitate
to unmute or wave.
Same for you Leisa.
Either type in the chat or raise your hand
or unmute.
JOE TURNBULL: I'm interested in the idea of
inter-generational stuff.
In my work with disability arts we work with
a lot of stalwarts of the disability arts
movement who were part of the direct action
network and there in the 70s or 80s, I guess
a generation before you at least Kate.
Maybe there's this change - it's gone from
that, which came from the agitprop politicised
way of making art, maybe it changed, hopefully
it's coming back again, but it seems the understanding
of disability itself is different between
generations, and it's important for that inter-generational
learning, learning from people who were there
decades ago fighting for rights, and learning
from the younger generation with fire in the
belly.
The idea of not reinventing the wheel, and
past work has been done, and there's stuff
to learn from that as well.
I'm rambling now.
IRENE VAN ZEELAND: I feel what you're saying,
it's nice to know whose shoulders you're standing
on and who got you where you are, but at the
same time not necessarily conforming to that
as the newer generation - it gives you roots
and a place you come from but doesn't necessarily
define where you have
to go.
KATE MARSH: Just in response Joe, this is
going to be a bit cynical - no, realistic
- I think you're right.
If we think back to our cultural or historic
legacy around disability activism, we have
that to build on.
We've had a period not connecting to that,
and we're back to a deeply politicised way
of being - not necessarily just politicised
around disability, it's more complicated than
that.
I don't think it's cynical, but I think it's
important, I think that's been forced by seismic
economic societal shifts that have actually
thrown disabled people back into extreme precarity.
I think that's what is happening, to some
extent.
That initial activism came from a place of
limited rights and real inequality, and it's
depressing but I think in the UK we're shifting
back to that, definitely in the pandemic.
I know artists who have been made hugely precarious
by government decisions, which forced us to
go, We're not having this.
It's almost from a place of having to, not
choosing to.
Maylis?
MAYLIS: Hi everyone.
Really happy to be here and listen to you
Kate.
It's been a long time - I heard from your
work and listened to a lot of interviews and
I'm really interested in what you do.
I'm also a disabled artist based in the French
Basque country.
I'm in a generation that is a bit in the middle
between your generation and the new generation,
generation Z.
I also think there is this shift going on
right now.
My question is, because I live in France and
maybe disability is not the same, we don't
talk about disability the same way in France
and the UK, and as a disabled artist I'm really
struggling sometimes to talk about my work
and what I do in a radical or political way,
because France is a very politically correct
country.
When you talk about disability it's about
the social aspect of it.
When you're in the culture, there is no funding
for inclusive dance as a cultural genre or
style.
It's not a question but a comment, is the
new world and new institutions really ready
for artists like me who are disabled and want
to do things differently, are they really
ready for us to come?
And how can we make them ready?
How can we push for our needs to be considered?
KATE MARSH: I think that's a really great
observation.
The first thing that interests me about what
you're saying is how often when we have really
cemented social or cultural understandings
of disability, however well meant, they can
make us invisible, and make it difficult to
have fluid or radical conversations because
as disabled people we become trapped in a
language and understanding that is put on
us, rather than one we choose.
Speaking personally I don't have a fixed sense
of my disability.
I have a fixed sense of my identity as a crip
person and disabled person, but within that
it changes all the time.
If someone layers on me, You need this today,
it's un-helpful in progressing and moving
things forward.
It's interesting the different geographic
contexts.
I had a conversation with a friend of mine,
not a dancer but a fluent French speaker who
lived in Holland many years.
Her work is around working with migrant cultures.
She said the same, that in France it's so
bound up it's difficult to have a truly progressive
conversation.
Just to say someone else said the same as
you.
I don't know what the answer is.
What excites me at the moment, and it's been
a strange twist of Covid, is I think we are
more connected, we can collectivise as disabled
people now across countries and contexts,
and I'm already feeling the power in that.
We've all felt connected to each other but
we can now come into virtual spaces and feel
supported and have an allyship between us,
rather than depending on non disabled gatekeepers.
I hope you and other disabled artists can
draw on that, even to go, Argh, this thing
happened and I'm frustrated.
Even practical things about writing about
your practice and putting it out to your network,
peers and crip friends and asking what they
read from the language, we need to capitalise
that more and lean into each other.
I really hear how frustrating it must be in
that context.
You'll all know Dan Daw, a good friend of
mine, and his practice.
We just worked on his solo show a bit.
We talked about the impact of being or feeling
like the only one.
We've probably all experienced that at one
point.
,It's really hard.
I'm excited about finding a way to connect
with each other so nobody has the feeling
they're on their own.
JOE TURNBULL: In the chat I encourage you
to look at in your own time, it was a great
event last night, real community, and rediscovering
the feeling from the beginning of lockdown
where it really felt like we were all together
again.
KATE MARSH: Was that Gareth and Gemma?
What a tiny world we're in.
I feel very proud of them, I did a programme
with the Arts Council called Change Makers
where we brought together 21 queer crip artists
together to collaborate, so I match-made them.
JOE TURNBULL: The event was really brilliant,
do catch up with it.
KATE MARSH: They're super exciting, I love
them.
JOE TURNBULL: It was really good.
The thing I wanted to ask about was in the
rush to reopen and all those things, when
so many in our community are still shielding,
how we navigate that as artists, whether that's
a conversation we should be having with venues.
There's that sense of disabled audiences and
performers getting left behind in the rush
to go back to normal, and whether there is
a role as artists and performers to be having
that conversation with venues if they're not
making provisions.
KATE MARSH: I was involved with two projects
in lockdown which I am very proud of.
First was called In Other Words, a book of
writing, musings, artworks by queer crip and
artists of colour.
The first book was around what does it feel
to be hurtling towards a new normal when normal
didn't mean anything to you in the first place.
It's beautiful, full of hope and anger.
The second book asks how are you now we're
in the new normal.
That's something we can do - when we have
facilities - because I did this with funding
and an arts organisation called Metal, and
we created space to bring people together
with their experiences.
The other slightly drier but important project
I did was Arts Council funded project called
the [DC44C].
It was me and 3 other disabled producers having
conversations with disabled people primarily
about audiences and artists.
When we asked the question what do you want
when we emerge, people said, please don't
change streaming, please don't marginalise
us for needing to be virtual, or punish us
for needing to shield.
That was loud and clear from everybody.
I think Joe your concerns are right - I'm
not sure venues in the capitalist model of
wanting to get back to money and fill auditoriums,
I'm not sure they're thinking about that.
The pragmatist in me says one solution is
let's get really clear on articulating that,
in policies, in riders performers put through,
and what we demand as audience members.
There is interesting stuff happening.
We need to amplify it so it becomes difficult
for venues not to stream work.
And also to nod to venues that do do it.
I work on and off with The Junction in Cambridge
who are brilliant and committed to streaming
and thinking about how to invite disabled
audience members into their venue and work
with disabled artists.
It's good to nod to good practice.
JOE TURNBULL: Absolutely.
I wonder if something like shared tools, or
if there's research that demonstrates how
excluded and left behind people are feeling,
if you include in artists riders that we could
circulate.
KATE MARSH: Sometimes we don't know what we
need.
I had a great conversation with [Cindri Renaud].
We had a really great conversation.
They said, I don't know what I need from Monday
to Friday.
It might change.
What I actually need from a venue is to understand
that's a changeable thing.
That's the same from audience members - to
understand we may not just need access - we
may need access meaning we can come in and
out, or come in late, or sneak out early.
I think some kind of toolkit or documentation
that articulates that for us would be really
good.
JOE TURNBULL: To be clear I don't think that
should fall on artists, it's the responsibility
of venues, but you get the opportunity sometimes
to have a dialogue with a venue and it's worth
taking that opportunity if you can, but it's
an extra burden on artists.
It's how we should make it easy for artists
to broach those conversations.
IRENE VAN ZEELAND: It links into something
you said in the video we shared about asking
people for advice and help.
Thinking about France, I live in France as
well, that's a huge difference between the
situation in France and the UK.
Thinking about that, you're advising younger
artists or artists in different countries
that don't have the same access as experienced
artists like you -
what would you What would be some of those
experiences that were crucial for you that
you want to share, if the person is not necessarily
coming to you, what are the things you feel
are really worth sharing in terms of experience.
If you look at for example the French context
where there is so much work to do, it feels
daunting to see how little there is and how
far it still has to come.
KATE MARSH: That's a huge question.
I think that - I actually think I've done
most of my profound learning in much smaller
contexts, actually when I haven't been trying
to break down a big wall.
I've done most of my really active learning
when I've been with my collaborator Welly
in the studio or working with a filmmaker
I work with.
That's where I'm really learning.
The reason that's complicated for me is because
I'm really aware I perhaps couldn't have learnt
that when I'm 20.
It's difficult to imagine going back and saying
to my 20 year old self, don't be in the mainstream,
be radical.
Because I was in a different place and everything
was different.
I don't know.
I'm trying to find a moment I'd want people
to know.
I think I'd want to say to all disabled people
who are in difficult geographic contexts or
whatever difficult contexts, to lean into,
or just be around the communities that are
- we're so closely knit as a community, across
countries I think as well.
I had an interesting meeting with colleagues
in Poland following the Polish lab I did in
October.
The British Council says what would you like
next, and they said, maybe to have Kate back,
and Candoco, and Stopgap, and Clare Cunningham.
I found myself thinking, is there a space
we can tap into the fact we all know each
other - so if you've got me, you've got access
to Clare, who is an email or phone call away.
Same with Maylis.
We have this conversation, we don't have to
go, Stopgap do this - we all know each other.
We can share information freely and point
each other - there is enough to go round,
is what I'm saying.
That feels really important.
IRENE VAN ZEELAND: That seems like very solid
advice, maybe not to be afraid to reach out
to people maybe in another country or maybe
you've only met them once.
The network is so tightly knit you can find
your way in.
That touched me you said that, ask us for
advice.
KATE MARSH: Also to get political, we, the
disabled, the crip community, are repressed,
are historically oppressed - not repressed
- and are oppressed now and looking at a future
of oppression.
That's not all we experience.
The reason I'm making that comment, is because
if you ask an oppressed person -
I'm a crip artist, but I've also gone through
arduous long processes of securing any benefit
related to my disability.
I know how that feels and know about objectification.
I'm not saying it's all about inclusive dance.
I regularly get objectified or marginalised
on my way to speak or to a performance - that
happens to me all the time.
If another disabled person reaches out to
me, of course I want to connect to them.
We automatically share something, not everything,
but we share this line.
I'm excited by that line, I don't think we
make enough of it.
I wrote something recently, I felt it was
important to say.
We don't automatically understand each other's
experiences, but we can go, I know something
about where you're at, a little bit of where
you're at.
That's got to be a good starting point for
a conversation.
IRENE VAN ZEELAND: That's really beautiful.
JOE TURNBULL: I had another question, totally
unrelated.
Just trying to think about people watching
this back, in Beyond Access there are a lot
of artists whose primary experiences are as
performers, and there are people whose primary
experience being a performer, moving to be
the creative force is a difficult transition.
Do you have any advice about how
you make your own language, how to develop
that voice.
How you go from realising someone else's creative
vision to developing your own practice.
KATE MARSH: That's such an important question,
because it's a transition so many performers
make.
I was in Candoco 5 years.
The way Candoco works is you are a dancer,
a tool, for someone primarily a non disabled
vision.
Which is - I'm making no comment around that,
but that's the reality of that situation.
I was a dancer for somebody else's idea of
what they wanted to say about disability.
It was a kind of accidental transition to
make work with Welly O Brien, my long term
friend and collaborator.
That was an easy transition, because it was
just the two of us, we'd both been in Candoco,
and were thinking about what we wanted to
say.
Sometimes we got it wrong, and it might be
different now.
That was a gentle transition.
I actually think getting into research is
where I found my voice and language.
I found it by resisting normative language,
by getting to a point of going, that language
doesn't work for me, that codified way of
making dance doesn't fit my body.
I started playing around with this messy language.
So much of my practice is about mess, in an
unapologetic way.
I want to welcome that mess and playing with
my practice, my language, and I think I said
this in the film you ve seen - I'm not always
- physically in life I feel really supported.
I feel part of a powerful small network of
disabled artists and researchers who I feel
have got me.
That gives me the ability, the confidence
to speak - and sorry Joe, this is probably
more answer than you wanted.
In my experience, that's what people want
to hear.
Even in the most highbrow conference, people
want to hear you speak from experience and
truthfully.
That doesn't always land well, but I'm stubborn
about doing that.
I'm not going to read a paper about Foucault
- although I do that occasionally.
IRENE VAN ZEELAND: I see Leisa you've joined.
Nice to see you.
Is there anything you'd like to share or ask
Kate?
LEISA: Kate thank you, what you said then
really helped me.
Because I have been doing ensemble work since
I started working with the arts.
I'm just about, later this year, to start
my first residency to create my own work in
Australia.
I must admit to being really scared up until
this point.
Then hearing you say that it's like, Yeah,
finally I don't have to do, say, move in somebody
else's curated way.
You saying, you make it messy, I'm going,
oh it's like a little bit of freedom.
I can be a hot mess for my first show.
Because I'm just figuring it all out really,
what I want to say.
I have the story and idea and vision in my
head, I've probably had it in my head 5-8
years, finally I get the chance to do it.
Hearing you say what you just said I'm feeling
more confident it will be a cracker or a show.
KATE MARSH: Can you see Maylis on screen.
Did you see her dancing when you were talking?
That's what I'm talking about, crip power,
you're not on your own.
Yes, that's good.
I want to be transparent.
My position is drop me an email or Facebook
message.
If you're in studio and create 10 minutes
of work and want an eye on it, even if I can't,
there is someone I know that can and will
want to.
Where in Australia will you be?
LEISA: In Melbourne, Victoria.
I'm currently in Bremen Germany at the moment.
KATE MARSH: Will you be able to access the
brilliant Caroline Bowditch?
LEISA: Yes, she used to be my boss.
There is a really good crip community in Melbourne.
I have every confidence, got a lot of people
being able to cast a critical eye.
It's so important we get to look at each other's
work and say great, or have you thought of
doing it this way?
KATE MARSH: I'm also a big believer it's fine
to share work with people who we know will
get it to say nice things.
To be clear, I want you to look and give it
a critical eye, or just because I want to
share it with somebody and not for critical
feedback.
Sometimes it's just good to put work out there
and know it's being seen, and say, this is
how I want you to comment.
I've learnt that from PhD supervision - when
someone sends you 10,000 words, it's good
for them to go, go through this with a fine
toothed comb - or, be gentle.
LEISA: I'm feeling so positive now, thank
you.
IRENE VAN ZEELAND: I'm going to slowly bring
this to a close.
Maylis if you have a last question maybe for
Kate.
MAYLIS: I'd like to ask Kate something around
leadership.
It was a part of the video too and I was very
interested in that.
I'm the artistic director of a collective
project.
We've been selected in [Proform] Europe.
We are going on tour next week, to Denmark,
Sweden, France, for 10 days.
We are very excited - but, it's been a journey.
It's been really, really tough.
I've found 3 incredible partners, programmers
in Denmark, Sweden France who were really
helpful, but it's been a lot of work, admin,
emails, a lot of production work.
It really put me into almost burnout last
week.
I was overwhelmed by anxiety and everything.
I'm an anxious person.
On my daily basis it is a part of who I am.
I try to embrace it as an artist, but we are
facing the fact being a leader, and anxious,
and an artistic director, I question whether
I chose the right career and path, because
I'm so anxious, and it's hard to be that anxious
and the leader of a project.
I was asking myself a question, can we start
a conversation around being a leader and being
anxious or having mental health problems?
Because it's a reality.
I know a lot of disabled people who deal with
anxiety on a daily basis.
Where are they?
Can we talk about this?
I feel lonely in this situation.
How can we bring anxiety and depression, and
all of this can impact our ability to send
email, be on time - can we talk about this,
and where?
It's part of leadership, but it's like, how
can we be leaders if we have to do the exact
same thing as non disabled people, when we
don't have the same lives as non disabled
people?
KATE MARSH: This feels so important.
Firstly, you're already doing it.
You've done it.
You have a 10 day tour.
You're doing it.
Second thing is absolutely, I feel passionately
- sorry to be the annoying person who references
their own PhD.
One thing I did in my PhD, credit to my supervisor,
is create a taxonomy around leadership, it
was about gentle leadership, I'd love to bring
anxious leadership into that.
It's alarming how even in the arts we're dominated
by a model of leadership from the top, survival
of the fittest.
It's so jarring with a crip or disabled experience.
We really need to own those things - I'm anxious
and anxiety feeds into my leadership.
I rarely go into something going, it's definitely
this.
I've learnt to embrace that's my leadership
style.
I like to have other people around me and
make decisions through conversation and discussion.
On a practical note, that's a lot, to be an
artistic director and producer and do the
administrative work.
Sometimes it's inevitable - you need to acknowledge,
that's three jobs.
Many artistic directors can just hand that
over.
You're already doing a lot.
On a practical thing I really love the way
Jess Thom, Tourettes Hero, is really open
about sharing their practice.
I love the way - I just worked with Jess,
who contributed to the second book I did.
Real clarity in we acknowledge and work in
crip time.
We don't always pick up emails between 9-5.
We might cancel last minute because of needs
of people we work with.
There is something that much be such a relief
- I'm getting better at doing that, there
is learning about this is what I can do, and
this is where my boundary is, for example
I don't answer an email, or don't want to
be in a WhatsApp group, or these are my days
or rehearsal times.
That takes bravery because we're pushing against
a traditional system.
It's important.
If we don't do that, we're setting ourselves
up to fail.
If you look at the history in the arts of
disabled people in non disability led organisations
undertaking leadership positions they're often
short lived.
The reason I think is because the person is
exhausting themselves trying to fit into a
normative pace and time of understanding work.
Until we can say, no this is what leadership
looks like for me - because politics and political
correctness is telling organisations they
have to involve disabled people, but if they
don't respect crip time, they're setting up
to fail.
There are loads of people saying - and actually
it's crip time, it is.
That's such an amazing philosophy I think
we can all learn from and work within.
JOE TURNBULL: In our organisation we do co-leadership
as well, co-chairs instead of having one chair
we have one disabled and one non disabled
chair.
Co-leadership models can be really helpful.
It's quite an established practice in the
arts to have an artistic leader and a chief
executive role on the practical side.
There are lots of examples like that.
Co-leadership can be helpful to cover each
other's bases.
It's impossible for one person to have all
the attributes needed sometimes.
KATE MARSH: Agreed, 100%.
IRENE VAN ZEELAND: Thank you so much, thank
you Kate for sharing all these very insightful
things.
Don't stop quoting your own PhD, I find it
incredibly fascinating.
Please continue quoting.
Thank you Leisa and Maylis for joining us,
thank you Joe for organising all this, and
our two that are hidden - Almudena, thank
you for setting it up, and thanks Eluned for
captioning, we'll use that also in the recorded
version probably.
KATE MARSH: Thanks Irene for holding us.
IRENE VAN ZEELAND: It was my absolute pleasure.
Thank you all for being here, I hope you walk
or roll away inspired from this conversation.